teurs donc du coup j'ai penché
pervenches est-ce que tu connais le
portrait chinois le portrait chinois
jeudi par exemple s'il était une fleur
quelles fleurs tu serais sûrement
marijuana c'est le piège
donc je vais pas répondre donc c'est
l'anti portrait chinois
j'y répondrai pas tu vas répondre si tu
étais un défaut un des fouets a redit
son nom facile c'est pas ça c'est comme
un joker tu peux le faire qu'une fois
oui eh ben je vais m'employer qu'une
fois à la gare mais c'est fait alors
j'étais une maladie une maladie nerveuse
curieux une maladie nerfs besoin est là
pitt maladies psychosomatiques qui donne
des plaques avant le rendez-vous
insultant ah ouais historienne et
surtout le toit le move et la mauvaise
plaques
je viens pour chercher du job d'un
rendez vous avec une fille oui moi je me
manifeste et tu sais pas comment me
soigner parce que c'est en toi la
solution la maladie de timsit way un
nerveux nerveux un insecte un insecte un
empire en petits morceaux
pas n'importe où le morpion dans une
petite forêt vierge comme ça d'une femme
du monde comme ça je dirais tout le
monde mais à toute la série journalistes
notamment au coq je peux changer le
personnes comme ça un microbe un microbe
âgées pas dire le gonocoque dira
peut-être là tiens il ya un microbe ce
n'est pas son nom mais il se passe par
la salive et c'est la maladie de l'amour
tu sais que ça te donne un manque de
globules blancs comme seul on dit ah
vous avez embrassé la panne sida non
c'est la salle email urines fallu
beaucoup plus chaud comme ça ouais ouais
ça toi c'est vrai il y en a un qui lui
va
aof icaunais en mononucléose les salons
chercher sans nom va d'accord on est
bien entouré
elle produit qui me l'a t-il s'il était
tué un dictateur avec mademoiselle je
veux bien un dictateur vrai peut-être
rêvé d'être en dit
dalet tout le monde se lève pour que tu
te support ouais gt1 vis à vis de plus
oui c'est trop faux pas je veux pas un
impôt à l'impôt sur les coûts le [ __ ]
je n osais on renfloue les caisses de
l'état tu me dois 300 bas depuis début
mai moi aussi je suis le premier à payer
c'était un [ __ ] un homme politique qui
respecte pas le jeu qui pense à lui
avant de penser à la nation ça c'est un
[ __ ] pas tous c'est bien ça weight
talons mais t'as vu des fois je compte
des froids mais moins à temps il ya
quelqu'un là on m'a soufflé ça m'arrive
en général c'est tout seul chez moi mais
là il est tard aux folies bergères je me
sens un peu chez moi
ouais
un bouton celui de ta sur le front à
cliquer là il fait mal
un supplice un supplice tu peux pas
répondre à redescendre algérien pour
nous ok ok l'antibois joker la chèvre
ouais super rebelle alors promis un
premier temps ma mère me le fais un
poison et un poison celui que tu as dans
le vert grâce à l'autopsié on va te dire
une infirmité nafia venir en trompette
et bah oui je me suis et attention c'est
un faux nez moi oui je me suis fait
refaire le nez
si c'était un assassin que tu serais
l'assassin eliot ness
[ __ ] mais t'as vu le nombre de mecs
qui bigou tendu j'étais pilote
il fait partie de la police ah ouais
eliot ness et site était infime
eliot ness je voudrais pas être dans ma
fille non je le connais en voyou leurs
bâches et jamais vu en flic m'a fait non
mais je demande à voir
tu vas voir laurent baffie le baril